hey there today i'm talking to sebastian
rizzi who is the director of the
creative ai lab and the co-director of
the robotics evolution and art lab at
the i.t university of copenhagen he's
also the co-founder of a company called
model ai that uses ai for various
aspects of game development specifically
today we're going to talk about a blog
post that sebastian wrote that's called
the future of artificial intelligence is
self-organizing and self-assembling
we're going to talk about systems that
have no supervised instance controlling
everything but contain little elements
that all need to somehow communicate
locally with their neighbors to come to
an agreement about the whole thing think
of something like an ant hill just
organizing in tiny parts to achieve a
bigger goal now we've had massive
success with these big supervised model
essentially a central instance
controlling everything and and that
works wonders for the problems that
we're currently solving however if you
think of things like the most complex
organisms that ever existed which is
probably human society at least as far
as we know that is not supervised that
has no central instance except the
illuminati but you know so essentially
human society is self-organizing and
self-assembling lots of little parts
making decisions on their own
communicating locally and what emerges
is this absolutely beautiful thing now
as you can imagine this is not
mainstream self-organizing and
self-assembling systems and related
things like open-ended and life-long
learning these are not the current hype
topics but i believe strongly that they
will be in the future things like this
will play a big role when we push beyond
the limits that we are definitely going
to hit when using supervised and
centrally controlled systems
applications of this are numerous i
already mentioned things like game
development in fact a lot of sebastian's
experiments are in things like minecraft
and other games just for visual you know
oomph in their research however the
applications are possibly unbounded and
could touch every area of ai and the
greater field of technology so join me
this interview was absolutely awesome
you should follow sebastian and follow
his research and the research of his
collaborators very very interesting i
like it it's out of the box it's new
it's creative it pushes beyond what i
know that is it for me we'll dive into
the interview i'll see you around bye
bye
hello everyone today i have sebastian
rizzi with me who is a professor at in
copenhagen working in the general field
of self-organizing and self-assembling
systems which is i think an entire
different world than the current
paradigm that we're used to we're used
to having our deep networks training
them really top-down with supervised
signals sometimes self-supervised but i
guess that's still kind of like a
top-down supervision there's gradient
descent there's all these things where
essentially an outsider outside us human
or some some constraint is globally
enforced and there's an entirely
different world
that goes much more
along the lines of nature and
that tries to come up with structure
from from the bottom up and that i find
this really cool
and is really promising
and i think it
sort of can solve problems that are
really hard to tackle with these
classical algorithms
and i think the the field is
upcoming even though it has existed for
a long time but i i believe that is
definitely worth to look at
so today we'll talk about uh
first and foremost this blog post the
future of artificial intelligence is
self-organizing and self-assembling but
also a bunch of other things in this
field
so sebastian
welcome and thank you so much for being
here thanks a lot for the invitation
very happy to to be here so
why
aren't you working on
just scaling deep learning more and more
to bigger and bigger models what's the
appeal of going like really small really
really modular
right um
yeah i think there i mean one reason is
that a lot of people working on
or in this field so i like to work on
things where there you know there's
there's maybe not so many people working
on it and i find this field particularly
exciting uh and we have seen that uh we
can scale up deep learning and it can do
like amazing things but we have also
seen that
these systems still tend to be quite
brittle so we have reinforcement
learning agents that
that
perform beyond
human capabilities in some domains but
then you add a single pixel in this kind
of the sock in this atari breakout and
the system completely fell down and
there are a lot of other examples like
image recognition examples where um you
slightly change an image or you rotate
slightly and instead of detecting a fire
bus it's detecting something else you
have examples of tesla
driving into like an airplane because it
mistakes it for something else so these
systems are amazing at a lot of things
but they're still very very brittle in
in other tasks and so
that's why i'm particularly interested
in this kind of idea of
collective systems and self-organization
because these systems have this inherent
kind of robustness you can take away
parts you can add parts
and the system will not completely break
down because there is no central leader
it's like a self-organizing process um a
collective system and that's what kind
of fascinates me um
and that's why i'm more recently we're
going a lot in this direction and and it
seems to be very fruitful direction
where there's a lot of interesting
things to discover that we haven't
really looked yet yet
i think as a motivating example we can
show this thing right here which is
a collection of what are called swarm
robots or here it's called a robot swarm
could you describe what is what is
happening right here what what are we
looking at right this is a like a great
work from radhika nagpul's group uh
where basically they have these kilobots
a thousand of them
and and they and they follow like a
specific algorithm and that allows these
thousands of kilowatts to assemble into
a certain shape like those shapes we see
like a star
a k and i think this this wrench
uh and and
and this system shows basically they
only have very limited um
information these kilowatts they can
only basically see their surroundings
but just by having this kind of local
communication
these kilowatts are able to uh over time
to assemble into different shapes um and
and so this was one of like the seminal
papers that showed that you can run
actually these kind of algorithms
inspired by nature on on a large scale
on a large swarm of robots
um
and and this is basically like one um
great example of this uh
what it kind of uh what limited it is
that those rules that those robots
follow like they have a specific plan
they needed to be designed by
humans so it's a human-made algorithm
they follow it and they can the you can
compile it into making different shapes
but what we are more interested in is
can we do similar things but can we
instead learn
these rules with recent deep learning
machine learning methods basically
combining this deep learning with ideas
from collective intelligence to create
even more complex
structures growing more complex
structures
it is i think reminds
a lot of people probably of something
like ant colonies um also maybe uh ev
not not necessarily evolution but the
development of just cellular organisms
in general where there's not really
well i'm going to step on some toes here
but an intelligent designer you know
directing every step of the process up
there is it fair to say that that these
things you said inspired by nature is it
fair to say that something like an ant
colony implements one of these
algorithms yeah exactly so so it's
inspired by um what you see in like uh
swarms of animals of insects doing like
ants they're like amazingly robust and
they have this kind of collective
intelligence that is bigger
they are made out of like simple units
but together they do like these amazing
kind of things and termites they build
these amazing structures and so i think
for this work it's actually um yeah i
think it was termites that was the main
inspiration for this and then you also
have the same thing in in um
the same kind of collective thing
happens when uh through morphogenesis
like when we are when we are grown
basically from one cell
by division and local communication it's
growing these like amazingly complex
structures uh and and both processes
show that um
by very simple rules you can get amazing
things
and and
there are many other examples and and
one thing that these systems have in
common is that you can remove parts and
it still kind of works which is very
different to our current like neural
networks where you just change something
slightly and oftentimes they will just
break down
i think yeah you demonstrate this later
by training robots and then
removing limbs of them and they can
still kind of adjust to it and i think
the the arch example of these local
rules you have also in your blog post
which is this game of life which is
obviously as you said these are hand
designed rules still give rise to like a
a really complex set of phenomenon which
is i believe even like undecidable uh
to to really decide from a starting
point
i'm not sure about the the lore behind
game of life
yeah exactly i mean they're basically
you can build any i mean with this it's
a universal uh computer basically you
can build any kind of uh program if you
that you would want with the cell
automata of course it would be like a
super massive
cell automata but they they as you said
they show that even these kind of simple
rules they give rise to things that
replicate things that move across the
screen uh and so people have found like
all kinds of amazing
structures by basically not changing the
rules but changing the starting
configuration of these kind of
cellular automata
when we think about combining this with
deep learning we quickly get to
these neural what are called neural
cellular automata
you have some examples right here and i
think i have the the website open
somewhere this is work that appeared in
in distil pub which
is obviously cool interactive journal so
this i think this was one of the first
even
articles to appear out of google
and
so this here i can maybe interact with
it you can destroy parts of it and it'll
kind of regrow it and all of this is
happening just by local interaction so
there's no there's no kind of global
organizing system that tells these
things what to do but every single pixel
in here essentially has a feature vector
and communicates with the neighbors and
how they communicate is am i correct to
say that
the way they communicate with each other
that is the part that is learned through
deep learning exactly yeah you can
imagine like you have basically a copy
of the same neural network like running
in each cell
and that and that network takes into
account like information from the
neighbors
the neighbors state and then it decides
what should uh what should the next
state of that pixel basically be and you
have these like rgb values that's one
thing it decides on but then it also has
these additional channels like hidden
channels that it can basically it can
decide what kind of information would be
good to communicate to my neighbors
and so this work was not like the first
that that used this neural
uh that used neural networks to learn
rules for seletometer but but it really
kind of revived the field and what it
did is that it showed that you can
actually it's you can make the whole
system differentiable
so so we tried similar things before
where we used evolution
uh to to optimize neural networks which
is this field neural evolution but it's
quite difficult for evolution if you
have a specific target in mind like you
want to grow this salamander or you want
to grow a certain other structure it's
quite hard for evolution to learn these
kind of supervised tasks and then
basically this paper showed then if you
have a target you can just use recent
tools like do autodiv differentiate to
the whole system and you can actually
efficiently learn
how to grow a certain structure that is
only grown through this local
communication of cells and that was one
of the that i think revived like the
whole field and there's a lot more
papers now using
neural networks for cell automata to
grow all kinds of things game levels
robots
is
is how do you
train such a thing you said the full
thing is differentiable and there is a
target in this case right is it is it
the is it the fact that
you
are in some starting state
do you let it evolve for a couple of
steps and then kind of measure the loss
and then do something like back
propagation through time yeah exactly
yeah yeah so so you let it grow and then
you measure like is it uh how close is
it to the to the final output and then
it gives you the error to correct it and
then they do all kinds of tricks like uh
that you want the system to be of course
robust that um if i let it grow for 50
steps
uh instead of like 20 i still want it to
look like
like a salamander so they do some kind
of they do a few tricks
um that that like doing it
stochastically and letting grow for
different amounts of of time um to to to
get the system to be that it grows and
it also kind of knows when to stop
growing because that's an important part
uh also in nature like if i if um
like if through morphogenesis there's uh
it grows an organ it should it should
know when to stop growing that organ and
and
like not grow forever so that's one
important ability of these systems is to
learn kind of when to stop
um
if you
were to let's say criticize this
particular work
um what would
what would your criticism be
uh what's still missing from this or
where is it weak yeah so this what this
showed is that it's um basically it it
doesn't if you would critique it you
would you could say that it does not
but that was also not the goal it
doesn't discover
the the structure itself it has a target
so it has some kind of human design
target like the salamander that is drawn
by a human
um and and so in that case that's one
limitation um so actually one follow-up
work um
that we will be published soon we
actually combined uh evolution and this
system where evolution we let evolution
come up with like uh um it's a
soft robot in that case
and evolution is good at discovering
like variety of different morphologies
and then we use basically this method to
make the structure very robust
so we let evolution discover the
structure and then we cut off all kinds
of limbs and let it regrow so combining
kind of the the creativity of evolution
with this kind of making things robust
uh through this gradient descent based
training
that is the yeah the work on soft robots
i've seen that it just looks really cool
uh
so this would be one thing that is that
is discovered this uh sort of kind of
hopping tripod yeah and and obviously
this um i think soft robotics in general
are
rather new feel than combining them up
with like evolving systems seems quite
appropriate so here's one with a cut off
limb
and
you it can learn to regrow
regrow it right how in general
how do you teach a self-organizing
system to regrow things do you have to
explicitly
like do you have to explicitly train it
to regrow things or is this just a
natural consequence out of how the
system was trained in the first place
yeah so sometimes it it can it often it
already has some inherent robustness but
it will without explicit training it
will probably not be able to do this
like perfectly
um and and it will be that it sometimes
works and sometimes doesn't so in these
cases we explicitly
uh and also in the case of the the work
by google like they explicitly like you
explicitly remove stuff
uh during the training process so that
you confront the system with you know
this kind of uh
this damage that it has to to recover
from um so it is it makes the system
more robust if you specifically train
for it and i guess in nature that's
probably one reason that the system had
to work for all these different
environments so there is a lot of like
it they were
um
in your aunt qualities sometimes you had
more sometimes you had less and so so
these systems are because of the way
that where they are evolved uh they also
show this kind of similar level of uh or
like superior level of robustness
at this point are we already at the
point where you would say
that this surpasses or this is very
advantageous to classical deep learning
or are we still in the realm where let's
say everything would be fairly possible
with classic supervised top-down deep
learning um
i i think like
this um it it would be possible to have
it
grow and recover but i think that the
the secret here is that it only uses
local communication basically you could
of course have a network that would uh i
don't know a network that you query that
would could like similarly to
all your work like
c compositional pattern producing
networks cppns where you query basically
each location
in space and you ask it what should the
voxel be
and of course these systems could then
if there's damage they could you could
ask them again and they could recover
but the trick here is is that it's only
based on local communication so if we
ever want these things to work in the
real world then it's really advantageous
to have things that that only require
local communication basically um and and
so that's one whole that's one goal is
that ultimately we want to take those
systems from also the simulation later
on and and
you know we have yeah we have some
initial work and we want to
really create complex things also in the
in the physical world
if you say in the in the physical world
because if i if i think of there was oh
no this was a this the paper um
the physical cellular automata is at
least a thing that is doable in the in
the real world
but if i think of something like i don't
know a tesla car or something like this
that is in the real world yet it is
still you know a central controller that
controls
the whole car and there is still top
down and so on and is also trained in
that way what are the types of physical
situations where these would really
their local communication would really
come in handy yeah like i could imagine
like let's say you have a
a building or something that could
automatically detect if it's damaged and
then you know it could like our you know
our skin
uh it um you know it's damaged and it's
it's regrowing it's it's uh self uh self
healing so you could ultimately i mean
this is like science fiction but imagine
a building and then you it gets damaged
and then automatically it recognizes
it's damaged and then it you know
automatically recovers from this damage
more other like science sci-fi is if you
have imagine you have a swarm of
nanobots they only can communicate
locally right but they have to figure
out their shape they have to figure out
their
what they can do in an environment so in
those situations this local
communication would be very advantageous
um i don't know if it would necessarily
be um
useful for these kind of you know tesla
this car example um but but i could
imagine a lot of other like application
areas or drones that have to coordinate
somehow together only being able to
sense each other locally um uh so more
this kind of in that areas uh one thing
i'm quite um yeah excited about is this
uh
getting this from like this 2d version
to a 3d version and then you can imagine
building all kinds of things and it
would automatically know you're building
uh you know a table or you're building a
chair or you're building this and this
um which which i think it's quite uh so
so this is one example also of um
so yeah the self-classifying endless
digits
where basically the system cannot only
be used to grow something but it can
also be used to self infer its own shape
so you build something out of small
components or you draw like a digit and
then by having the cells communicate
with each other they figure out oh i'm
part of an eight or i'm part of a one
and so basically this is then what we
replicated in in this physical where you
can put them together make digits and
then each
each of these cells would tell would
figure out what part what shape am i
part of
so this um this is a physical
instantiation of the demo i have here
online this is another distal article
where as you exactly said these things
they figure out themselves what they're
part of and you made you made this this
is your paper into a physical
instantiation which i find really cool
and now you're taking it to 3d right
yeah yeah that's the that's the plan
yeah and of course currently these
systems
like this kind of self-classifying
endless digits it it does not work as
well as like using like uh like
state-of-the-art uh deep uh
convolutional network or transformer or
what what you have
but but i think ultimately um these
systems maybe we can integrate some
ideas also for things like object
detection to make these systems kind of
more robust by having a more kind of
distributed object detection where you
have this system where
the components maybe it could be a
combination of something convolutional
and
but then you have the system on top
where you have this local communication
and they figure out together kind of
what shape am i looking at and maybe
that could make these systems also
uh more robust in the future
and maybe less prone to kind of this
adversarial attacks that we currently
see
these systems still exhibit
has anyone tried with like maybe this
would be interesting like to take
something like this
and try to like make an adversarial i
don't even know how that would look like
but something that a human would clearly
classify as like a seven but there's
like a slight twist
yeah
yeah yeah i'm not sure people have
actually studied it so much on this uh
trying to to see how what kind of
adversarial attacks these systems could
i mean
like you could fool them i'm sure there
are also some
uh but uh
maybe the combination of kind of both
this and the more classic deep
uh image recognition techniques could
could make them more robust
so you've taken also this idea of this
2d
cellular automata and you've applied
this in 3d here in in minecraft which
uh so this is a more for morphogenesis
how do you how would you define
morphogenesis just quickly yeah i would
define morphogenesis as uh like growing
a complex structure based also on this
kind of local communication so how our
like bodies are grown is morphogenesis
how our like organs are grown how our
nervous systems has grown basically uh
from like uh you know a single starting
cell
and so this is what we do here and again
the structures are not found by the
system itself like we
took like an existing apartment building
uh and then we trained the system in the
same supervised way to regrow it
basically
um
and we were surprised that it could also
grow like these kind of functional
machines we actually had it growing like
like this temple and then we found that
the trap in this temple still worked
uh so because it had all the components
like there was not one single mistake
and that allowed these kind of
functional things to still to still work
like this kind of
like caterpillar you see there
and can you can you you you also said
you can destroy part of it and it will
regrow right which
yeah is this have you made this playable
somewhere in minecraft itself or is this
just purely your yeah currently it's
it's not i mean you can download the
code and stuff but it's not that we have
a server where you can play with those
things but it would be very interesting
we actually we organized this um
minecraft open-endedness competition
where we like a related field like can
you have an algorithm that can like
natural evolution create all kinds of
novel things without limits
and that's also where we use this
minecraft
framework um but it would be real fun
like one thing that i that i want to try
to also pursue in the future imagine you
don't have it grow like caterpillars but
you have it grow like cities and then
depending on the environment that you as
the humans decide like the mountains or
like uh the desert it would grow a
different type of city
uh so so so like
that's one thing we're looking at now
how can you incorporate also feedback
back into the album because this
caterpillar will always grow the same
caterpillar but if if i put this
caterpillar in a in a small box it
should maybe grow a small caterpillar
and if it's a large box it should grow a
large caterpillar so how can you kind of
incorporate this environmental feedback
um that's another thing that i'm um
very curious about
yeah is do you see beyond beyond gaming
maybe which which i can definitely see
applications of this do you see
applications uh that are not in the
physical world as we talked before but
but maybe in the in the still in the
realm of the digital world um are there
applications
i don't know what what what all you
you're thinking of but
uh
distributed applications networking
applications any sort of things that
you're very excited about that maybe
aren't super obvious if you just see the
the minecraft example right i mean one
thing that we are
basically i think like two things one is
like just this minecraft i think could
also ultimately teach us something about
uh uh biology itself
so so if we can because we don't know
everything yet about how this exact
morphogenesis process works in nature i
mean we know a lot of things but we
don't know for example how is it so
accurate like and and and uh so so
there's certain things that that we're
we're we don't know yet and so by
simulating this process like a very
simplified model but maybe there's
things we can learn from these kind of
very simple models
uh so that's one one area i'm also very
excited about and and
so so taking these systems to to as a as
a very simplified models biology to
learn something um the other thing the
other application area um
is uh
what i'm excited about is using those
things but instead of growing minecraft
structures you can grow actually
artificial neural networks
so so so you're basically kind of
replicating our brains are not like
designed and fixed they are grown like
through this developmental process
so what what we did with this recent
work this hyper nca is taking basically
instead of having growing um
a caterpillar we grow a pattern and then
we then we with a neural cell automata
and then we convert that pattern into a
policy network and that policy network
then is uh we can use this for our rl
task for example
so that's one one area i'm very excited
about and making this systems more
more
performant because currently we applied
to quite simple problems but i think
ultimately this kind of idea of
uh this growing neural networks
is could be very powerful because that's
how you know our brains are are created
so so so we're trying to replicate that
process uh hoping to create also more
more adaptive basically neural networks
what do i gain out of so in this here i
have these uh developmental steps on the
left i do i essentially start with some
configuration of weights essentially and
then i let the cellular automata run for
a number of steps self-organizing here
then i take it into a network and then i
execute the network and presumably i
have to learn this somehow in this paper
what you are doing is you're using if i
recall correctly a variant of
evolutionary search right i could also
like
in whatever way i learn it i i somehow
have to learn how the cellular automata
here reacts what do i gain out of this
instead of just training my policy now
right so so far i would say it's the
uh you you don't gain so much directly
so so far this method it's not that they
outperform like current uh dbrl methods
uh but ultimately basically there is
this um
this hypothesis uh also popularized more
recently by tony zador this kind of
genomic bottleneck hypothesis that means
that we only have you know 20 000 genes
and they they they guide the growth and
self-organization of our brains with
trillions of connections and and and so
it's a much smaller
genotype that encodes a much larger
structure
and so this kind of compression is
hypothesized to also allows us to and
animals to deal with situations they
haven't seen like to do basically that
the robustness that animals show is part
because they have to go through this
bottleneck this compression and this is
the information you give to the next
generation so there's some limit on the
information you can get so that might
bias the system towards learning rules
that generalize well like learning rules
that generalize well and and so this is
the the hypothesis here that at some
point we can have a very small neural
cell automata which is basically like
the the genome and that encodes a much
larger network and that hopefully would
then be more robust but that's something
we we have um
that's basically what we're working on
which we which we haven't really shown
yet but that's the that's the hypothesis
and the hope um
one other thing that's kind of funny
that it can do like it it can
uh you can basically
let the growth continue and not just
have one network grown but multiple
networks so like and we applied this to
this quadruped domain so we had it grow
for for 10 steps to grow one brain like
one neuron network then we put it into
this quadruped then we have a slightly
larger quadruped so we let it grow for a
little longer and then put it in the
middle quadruped and then have a larger
one so and so basically one nca can grow
multiple different neural networks
and and
that's also one thing that i'm pretty
excited about that we want to apply also
for like
more complex domains
and again here you had an experiment
with with where you damaged these
quarter pads
and
the system is able to adjust can you
explain how this system is able to
adjust to a damaged morphology like i
cut off a limb right so here it was
basically trained to on these like on
all these different morphologies and
then we had it basically
by continuing the growth you can get a
controller that was trained for one
morphology and then you continue it and
you get a controller that that works for
m2 and you let it grow a little longer
and it has a morphology for m3
so so in this case those were basically
seen during uh some other experiments we
have results where it has damage that
was not seen during training here
basically was trained to being able to
deal with this particular type
so if we would damage it in another way
it probably wouldn't work anymore with
these metamorphosis networks um
but um
yeah so and the hope is also that if you
know how to control one croto pet
then there should be
you that you don't have to start
basically from scratch there should be
some information there that allows you
to also grow something that is related
and not having to start like all over
again basically
this flows i think into a lot of a lot
of ideas from as you said the open-ended
community and the sort of uh
don't don't have explicit goals
community uh i think parts of your blog
posts and papers mentioned algorithms
like quality diversity map elites and
things like this which are obviously
very exciting and very different from
how we do deep learning uh today
so so far we've always looked at
uh things that have either an explicit
goal like here is the salamander i want
to build or here is the minecraft
structure i want to build or have some
sort of uh
i want to say
goal in an in a more abstract sense like
the reinforcement learning goal of
maximizing the height in this case right
for these robots then stand on on top of
one another yet how do we go
away from this is there is there a
natural progression in these
self-organizing systems to go away from
having explicit goals that would be more
difficult to pursue with like the
classic deep learning systems right i
think in general so i think that
like two things like one is the
representation which i think these
neural cell automata are like a great
representation for a lot of like growing
structures growing neural networks and
then yeah the other thing is you
mentioned is like the the search how do
we how do we actually get to
uh
systems that that
that show interesting these interesting
properties and and so there seems to be
a recent trend i mean not just in these
self-organizing systems but in also in
deep rl um in general to not train on
one thing basically but train on a
variety of uh different things so there
was also this uh
more recent paper by um i think it was
deepmind where they this xln that they
showed like basically if you train
agents in a lot of different changing
environments they they become they
develop more robust skills basically
um so so i think um
basically here it's we we also we
what i think it makes these cell
phonizing systems quite difficult to
train
is that these landscapes um the the
fitness landscapes basically they're
they're probably very kind of uh not
very smooth because changing like
something small
uh in these self-organizing systems can
have like this cascading effect
um so so that's why these traditional
objective based
uh rewards
they they work but then they don't it's
still difficult to optimize so that's
why we're more looking into this kind of
open-ended like what you mentioned
quality diversity methods basically
where we're not trying to optimize for
one particular outcome but we're trying
to find things that differ in some
interesting ways basically
uh and i think those methods
particularly for this kind of
self-organization
um they they are very uh very powerful
basically
um in in that they are better at
navigating like these kind of very
complex landscapes with many local uh
optima
but they're also slightly more um
expensive because they're they're
looking at a larger space of this of the
search space basically
what um
maybe these two questions in one uh
given given these outlooks
what field that
deep learning is good at right now do
you expect these methods to be better
if you know let's say if we invest the
resources and figure out you know the
tricks of the trade enough
what parts that deep learning is good at
now could these methods overtake deep
learning and then on the other hand
what's kind of the
for you the most exciting
area that we haven't even unlocked yet
with deep learning that are accessible
with this
like so it's two different two different
things but i'm i'm wondering about what
you think about both of these directions
right uh so so i think it's it's also i
wouldn't say like
overtake
deep learning i mean we use basically we
use deep learning as a as a tool
for
basically like kind of train these
systems so so i think yeah
sorry i mean deep learning and like that
just the thing we do right now right we
have objective loss
supervised training single neural
network uh so so i i would assume that
um
these systems would be able to have a
lot of different domains i think the one
kind of
probably the
the closest i think what we would see is
that they would
make rl agents more uh you know like
more robust more adaptive uh and that's
also already in this work that you that
we have there is like where we have
basically um
uh in this case we we trained uh not
only the we we have completely random
weights and we only trained local update
rules basically heaven rules and then we
show that to this system we can actually
during the lifetime cut off a leg again
we are always somehow mutilating these
uh
these robots we're not very nice to them
uh but but basically this is an example
i think where where we already show that
is this this is this
is more adaptive
than the current or rl design so so in
the current basically deep rl
i think the one main
drawback is that we train a system and
then we freeze the neural network and
then let it do its task so and this
seems like kind of very unnatural that
like you have a frozen brain okay maybe
you have like some recurrent connection
that allow you to learn something uh but
but uh basically we we have this
training period
then we freeze everything in the system
and we apply it to domain so that's not
like lifetime learning in in normally
these systems but the idea here is on
general self-organization that we never
wanted to stop learning we never wanted
to stop adapting we want the
self-organizing process to happening the
whole time so i think in any domain
where there are things that you might
not have um
anticipated during test time
these systems could be beneficial like
might it be there's a pixel added you're
losing a lag or or you wanted to do
something else i think that they already
show that there's some
they can be superior in in in those
domains
um
and that's one thing that i'm um
pretty excited about to to apply them to
more complicated domains not just these
like quadruped locomotion tasks
basically
but but anything where you you have
something
unanticipated happening i think there
there will be can be a benefit
of it
and then um
[Music]
was the second question um
like what other a new area that we
haven't even like we have no chance
currently of tackling with our tools uh
yeah that's a great question um
i mean i think this new area is this
kind of rapid lifetime adaptation
basically i think these systems are
great for if
you know what you would expect
but things like basically like having
things that work in unknown environments
i think that's a that's a really um i
think exciting area that i mean you have
like animals in nature and you you you
can put a dog into a new environment and
will not completely like break down and
will still know kind of what to do and
to interact with the environment and we
don't have that yet for our agents like
we can put them in environments they're
trained for you put them too far out
they they don't know what to do so so
and and i think that too that's
um
so this working in unknown environments
and also having this kind of like uh you
know common sense i think is maybe also
an area i think in the future that these
systems could be applied to although i
don't know exactly how but but that
these systems
they have more common sense and don't
directly break down like kind of giving
them
this kind of innate abilities that we
humans are born with animals are uh some
animals are born with uh that allows
them to um
to
yeah
uh
do a little bit more common sense things
uh than than currently learning system
that that don't have that property
basically
and this i think you you say it even
here at some point
this
in addition to the fact that there is
this genomic bottleneck right you
already said this
the genes
encode or only have the capacity to
encode very little information and what
we're doing here is we're learning
essentially the rules to learn the rules
which can be compressed in a much better
way than the rules themselves and
there is a reason to assume that this
will result in that kind of common sense
that if you have to essentially learn
the meta rule then that will make you
generalize better i mean it's an it's an
argument i'm not super convinced yet
right but if you do then some parameter
sharing you showed in some experiments
you can compress this even further so
that might be a way to tackle that and
also this uh in in tony zador's paper he
actually he points out that
um
this bottleneck like there's some
organs in nature that have many more
genes for example so maybe it is a
feature that we have that number of
genes that it's compressed and so so
that gives us like some
hope that also having a similar feature
in our artificial system should be
beneficial but but we're still
uh we only showed that for very very
simple you know
simple tasks so far
and deep learning goes into the exact
opposite directions right we're like the
more the more parameters the better we
have the double descent phenomenon and
and we can go essentially infinite and
and it always gets better which is which
is weird right um which is also giving
amazing results i think recently with
you know the the whole language models
and so on so it's definitely it could it
would be cool if in the near future
people discover like a fundamental
connection between you know the the good
results we get by scaling up and the the
actual principle from biology which is
seems to be more like compressing and
scaling down it would be nice if those
were to join together somehow yeah and
hopefully we'll we can be part of that
in in uh
to some extent but yeah i agree it's
it's really interesting that
like that you yeah you scale up networks
and then your local optima disappear
like everything just works better and
and here we basically we want to go the
opposite direction uh but it's not
necessarily that we
of course we still want our the final
models to have trillions of of um of uh
like connections but we what we
basically want is we want the trainable
parameters to be
low
and i think that that's the fundamental
difference that
we have a small number of training or
relatively small number of training
permissions but they give rise to much
more complicated system
exploiting things like self-organization
growth over time
and
yeah
this is i think
because you said before you're not
you're not an opponent of deep learning
in fact deep learning is used inside of
these cellular automata to to sort of
learn these rules i find it interesting
if you look in nature that there are
cells and they self-organize in some way
right by whatever means that is learned
but these cells then make up brains
right and brains are naturally very
top-down planners they're they're
they're in the moment they you know look
ahead and then the brains somehow
organize into societies and the
societies again are very distributed
very local very interaction on a
person-to-person level uh what do you
what do you make of this do you do you
think there is like an optimal uh
switch from
local to global to local to global that
we could sort of stack on top of one
another or is this just a happenstance
of of the universe yeah that's a yeah
that's a that's a great question um
[Music]
yeah and even more like the the humans
in the societies they organize
themselves into hierarchies right yeah
there's top down control and somehow it
gets even greater it's a good question
do we need i want yeah do we need all of
this in our artificial systems maybe we
need all of this to get to real like
more general uh artificial intelligence
like because also one thing that is
really crucial
is the the our culture right like be
like if you if you um i was reading this
great book recently like if you just put
uh humans somewhere by themselves
they are not very like um
you know uh
good at surviving but we are good at
surviving because we have all this
cultural information like all this uh
knowledge that other people made that
that we can build on
and that allows us to do all these
amazing things so so maybe to get our
ais to do really uh amazing things it's
not enough to having
like single agents in complex
environments but it needs to be multiple
age and they need to be simulated maybe
over multiple generations so there can
be some cultural knowledge transferred
from some agents to other agents
similarly to how how how it happens in
in
for us
but of course that also
makes the simulations much more complex
and expensive if you when you have to
simulate cultures multiple like
generations and
then we need some more better compute
especially at the university level
i think yeah that's one advantage that
nature has it has lots of lots of
distributed compute available that
said that there is there is an
interesting part in your blog post where
you describe sort of how to train these
things um or how to steer the
development
of these swarm systems or distributed
systems one one quote here you have is
guiding a swarm system can only be done
as a shepherd would drive a herd by
applying force at crucial leverage
points by subverting the natural
tendencies of the system and then
another one is
the self-assembling brain knows no
shortcuts in
which your i believe your argument was a
little bit that is very hard to predict
what a change does until you observe it
because the interactions can be kind of
uh
non-linear very dynamic very very hard
to predict you know that was basically
the argument that hissing are made in
his this great book like self-organizing
no self-assembling brain uh and and
basically that you need to basically the
system needs this process of growth and
and you have to put energy into it to
observe the outcome you cannot predict
and that's also things they showed that
warfarin what you showed with simple 1d
cell automata you cannot predict
the the state of the system you have to
actually run the system even if it's a
simple 1d cell automata
and that is also apparently the question
is do we also need to do that for to
growing our neural networks instead of
like designing them maybe we need to go
through this kind of process of growth
uh with learned rules to to
really unlock you know what these
systems can do
there is recent work in using for
example gans or so to predict things
like fluid dynamics and you know they
can't do it like super like they're not
extremely accurate but they can give a
pretty good
estimate of given starting state and
then a highly dynamic non-linear system
and then they can predict some steps
into the future i've seen the same like
galaxy development and so on uh
is there any happening like this where
you can say well i don't i can't i don't
have enough compute to run all these
swarms but i can sort of train
a surrogate model that will give me the
end in sort of a one-step fashion and
then these the the forces that i poke at
this format i could determine those
using the surrogate model yeah i think
that would be really interesting i
wonder i think it's
it could work for some limited steps in
the future but but but i think you you
would still need to
you know like
like at some point you need to basically
run this this model i mean maybe in the
first like generations you could help
they have sugar model that somehow helps
you to sort out like the things that are
really bad like uh this will not grow
into anything um
so i think you could use it there later
i guess you would probably have to to
run the system like when things get more
complex
um but but i think there's also another
role for these surrogate models which um
uh something i always wanted to try to
predict basically the learning abilities
of these systems so you have an agent in
an environment
so maybe you don't need to simulate the
whole lifetime right but you can have
someone like some kind of
some test that would test is this agent
how capable is this agent so having some
kind of surrogate that would could look
at certain parts of i don't know the
neural network and already predict will
this be a good learner or or not
basically um
but um
yeah
it is uh
in the in one part you also
it has very
can very
remember like i got into machine
learning and graphical models were the
hot thing at that point it was like just
before deep learning and this reminds me
all these self-organizing systems with
the local communication they remind me a
lot of
belief propagation things like this
graph neural networks obviously are
right now up and coming let's say do you
see connections between all of those
things or is that just kind of a
superficial connection yeah i definitely
see there's a big connection to these
also these graph new networks basically
like i mean they're very close to like a
more generalized form basically of like
a cell automata where you have different
basically neighborhoods depending on
your the topology of the graph and they
also seem to be there i think they're
super interesting um
i also actually how i got into neural
networks is the the first lecture i had
as an undergrad
uh was actually on neural networks and
about um these self-organizing maps
which uh um these cohonen salvanizing
that that basically can do clustering
uh
um based on uh some are like kind of
like means but on a
on a much more um they can do it better
and you have to get these like nice
visualizations out of them
and apparently there's also some process
in our brain i mean we have these
topographic maps
also in our brain so i was always
fascinated somehow by these summarizing
maps and even though i did a lot of like
some other things during my phd somehow
now i'm coming back to this kind of self
organization
uh and and uh and um
yeah using these recent deep learning
tools it's uh i think we can really
unlock like the power behind them there
was a do you know the arc challenge the
abstract reasoning corpus by francois
yeah yeah yeah
um there is i'm not sure if they have an
example right here so for everyone who
doesn't know this this is a task where
you get so the left ones are
demonstration examples there's always
like an input grid and an output grid
and then you get a test example where
you only get the input so here the rule
i've looked at that before so the rule
is kind of there is the gray in the
middle and you kind of fold the the
right hand side onto the left hand side
and then
you the solution here on the right hand
side is kind of the the sum of the two
and
this is
these are things that humans are
surprisingly good at
um but are very difficult for a machine
to learn and
the this is a data set and the training
examples there are not many training
examples so there is not really a way to
to learn this through brute force
training there is a little game
um that people can play i think i've
reported on this before but there is a
game for anyone who's interested where
this is the ark game you can find it on
the github page on of of
alexey borsky
and you can just choose one here they're
divided into different levels and yeah
you can you can try them for yourself so
oh this this looks even familiar like
cellular automata do you think that
like
self-organizing systems in one way or
another in the way we've looked at them
today or in the way you've seen them
could be useful
in solving challenges like these because
challenges like these are related
very much to
let's say
something that we would call
intelligence
yeah i think the the
the hope would be that if we can get
this kind of bottleneck algorithms to
work where we exploit so i'm not sure
like we could apply like
self-organization directly but what i
could imagine is that we
exploit develop these kind of genomic
bottleneck algorithms
that can guide this self-organization
growth of a very complex neural network
and that that network then could maybe
be used for this kind of task and and
the hope would be that because it has
this compression it would maybe
uh develop an algorithm that would allow
it to you know solve these kind of uh
yeah tasks that require more like high
level cognitive skills
but but of course that's still
yeah we're still a little far away from
that i think
and i guess i don't know what the
current state of the art in this task is
um how
i think it's
i think it's still largely on sale
so this could be a great test domain i
think but uh
yeah i think i
i'm not sure i have high hopes that it
would already like i think we're still
probably missing some other ingredients
uh
that we don't have yet to kind of make
progress there
um yeah but by the way this i think i
just clicked on on one randomly but i
think here the rule as i think if if
people get it they can see that you
always kind of select the smallest of
the shapes that is there and kind of
replicate it you know i i at least
that's my that's my hypothesis right uh
yeah
maybe
oh i think maybe you take the one that
fits in the box
oh yeah yeah yeah
right
but it is like this this this kind of
like you need to understand what shapes
are and so on so that is very much that
uh this is very high level this is very
bottlenecky it has a bottlenecky feel to
it like you're probably not going to get
very far with like a cnn trained on
these pixels directly uh so that's
that's i i can see
something like this uh very much
um be in the domain of of like first
open-endedness but then also
self-organizing things made up like
simple rules making up something very
complex there's other two other domains
that i that uh i think also very
exciting like one is this animal ai
benchmark where basically they uh it's
like an mlai olympics where you apply
ai's to tasks that animals normally are
good at like um
and like for example trying to figure
out which one is the tool and then you
use that tool to you know get a reward
uh and so there's also where current
methods basically they've pretty much
failed on more complicated tasks and
then they also had administrative
experiments where they had children
perform these tasks and they are still
much better
and then like any of our dbrl methods so
in the simple task the rl performs
pretty well once it gets to more
complicated things um then they the
system basically uh um
these systems fail so so this is one
task that that um
like uh in the recent grant proposal
that i proposed that that
there would be a good test domain for
these methods basically
because the whole point is to to act in
an environment that you haven't seen
during training
even though the environment is made out
of the same building blocks like there's
rewards there's like barriers
uh but how they are composed uh
all of this is new basically um and
never seen before
um and the other one is this uh also by
i think was the mind this alchemy task
where you have to learn to kind of um
it's a task that we have to learn
basically about the structure of the
domain what things you can put together
and then you have to use that knowledge
to like building on that knowledge
basically and this is also a very
difficult task for all of our current
methods so i think this could also be
very good tasks to um
to basically as the north star to drive
these the progress in in this kind of
area and i the hope is that this kind of
self organizing system
um
they should be
hopefully would be better in in this
where can people if someone wants to get
started in diving into the world of of
self-organizing systems uh swarm
intelligence maybe a bit of
open-endedness is there a good place for
people to get started like get their
their their feet yeah i i would say i
was recently rereading
this great book from
melanie mitchell this complexity
i think this is a great starting book on
on kind of this ideas of complex system
self-organization
uh there's something about cellular
automata in there so i think this is a
this is a good kind of
good point to get a broader overview of
of that kind of whole field of basically
complex systems organization
um
and
um yeah and hopefully the also the
the blog post hopefully can be helpful
to some people and also plan to write
more on on that as well
uh but but this i would suggest this is
a this is definitely a good place to
start
and is there um
some
some you know in
in deep learning it's usually keras i
train a cnn on mnist or c410 is there
like some some standard thing that every
one of your of your students goes
through i mean now i i send a lot of
them to this great distill article
basically and looking at this this
growing ncaas because they also have a
great um like this up notebook where you
can play with the system so i think this
is a great starting point to where you
both have
neural like you have cell automata and
you have like how recent tools can be
used to grow them so i think this is a
good good
place to play around with basically
okay
yeah i've i've spent more than
more than uh more time than i wanted on
these things because they're quite it's
great that it's also so interactive and
it's fun to play yeah
yes definitely um yeah i think is there
anything else that you would like to get
out there to to people about this field
yeah i just yeah i hope that people
would be
not only everybody running basically in
the same direction just doing like what
everybody else is doing so so hopefully
[Music]
this will be also
get a few more people into this field of
complex systems and and self
self-organizing systems and combining
the ideas of deep learning um because i
think there's a lot of
things interesting things to discover
basically here and and a little bit less
people working on it than
um than the like
like working on foundation models and
language models and all those
other things
yeah it's certainly i i think i think is
certainly an interesting area and i
guess especially if you're at a
university without the super duper
clusters uh probably just strategically
a phd
in this field would
maybe be more of an
advantageous position for new newcomers
actually like um
hinton had this great uh
uh
quote recently on this um
other podcast like it's always a good
idea to figure out what huge numbers of
very smart people are working on and to
work on something else
uh because you don't want to do maybe
what what everybody else is doing um
and and i think so i would suggest
this is a great field where a lot of i
think interesting discoveries basically
waiting to happen um yeah
i agree
uh all right so sebastian thank you very
much for being here today this was very
yeah thanks for the internet
i hope to see yeah i hope to see a
sprawling future for your feelings
thanks a lot thanks
[Music]